a previous version of this video was
demonetised by manual review despite the
fact that youtube's advertiser friendly
guidelines specifically state historical
events are generally allowed to monetize
if presented within the context of a
documentary or historical debate this
video is very clearly about history and
derived from a lecture I delivered in a
college classroom because this is a very
important subject for American history
if that doesn't fit their advertiser
guidelines for educational content then
they don't know what education means so
since YouTube won't support this kind of
content please consider buying some
merch or donating to my patreon all of
which are linked in the description
since YouTube not only doesn't support
education but is blatantly willing to
violate their own advertiser friendly
guidelines Hey Seifer here I've talked a
lot about the Lost Cause myth on this
channel mostly to denigrate it after all
today those who believe in it are
nothing more than conspiracy theorists
and are merely spouting it off as a form
of hatred but here's the thing it didn't
start off as a hateful ideology and has
played an integral role in u.s. history
just as it is important to understand
the origins of the Ku Klux Klan it is
important to understand the origins of
the Lost Cause myth and the fact is it's
held a pretty legitimate space in our
history for a very long time including a
number of historians / pounding it and
not just Woodrow Wilson who after all
was actually one of its main proponents
and we'll get to that but I want to
start this off by saying this is an
exercise in what sunsoo said know thine
enemy for while we should absolutely
denounce people who are spouting off
this myth today Lost Cause er
[Music]
we should realize the role the Lost
Cause myth played in American history so
the lost cause of the Confederate States
of America is a mythology that eulogizes
the Confederacy
since it is a mythology it is not a
clear movement one can hold any number
of tenants and be a lost cause er and
not even realize it for that's the
pernicious effect of mythology so
there's some general tenants that can
easily identify a lost cause er and all
of these are often tinged with overt
racism today but that wasn't exactly
always the case some of these were
actually believed and we'll see why so
the first one was that slavery was good
for the slaves you could see this part
of myth growing before the South even
arose pro-slavery advocates in the 1850s
often talked about how slavery was
supposedly beneficial for those who were
enslaved that it was a teaching
experience as they became more civilized
or that it was a means of fighting off
socialism and mind you when these guys
were referring to socialism this is
before even the lengths of Karl Marx
really started to take hold of the
movement so they're talking about like
Saint Simone and those guys the utopian
socialists as they're often called and
there's a wealth of literature about
these pro-slavery advocates for instance
you had guys like James Henry thorn well
who as one historian says unlike
capitalism or communism which Thornwell
believed altered social norms he avowed
that slavery was part of the social
fabric and therefore unalterable he even
believed that southern slaves had better
lives than the British working class and
you've heard a lot of that kind of
rhetoric with pro-slavery southerners in
the 1850s so of course that got in court
paraded into the general myth the next
part is probably the one that you'll see
the most on the Internet they are either
downplay or deny slavery's role in the
causation of the Civil War normally
they'll cloak it with things like states
rights or southern loyalty and in fact
they'll go out of their way
to lionize southerners loyalty so
they'll bring up tariffs and differences
in general culture and economics as if
all of those issues weren't underwritten
by slavery and when talking about the
Civil War itself they emphasize
northerner aggression in fact sometimes
you'll hear them call the Civil War the
War of Northern Aggression
you see they portray the war as
defending their homelands who were
simply trying to become their own
country after the United States had
somehow failed them and then once the
war was over of course then they have to
reconstruct reconstruction so they
portray reconstruction as punitive as
though the Republicans were going out of
their way to destroy the south and wreak
havoc just to punish the south for even
having attempted to secede they'll
especially deny the Civil Rights Act and
the various Reconstruction Amendments
and then portray the US military who
were there to enforce the Civil Rights
Acts as a form of further punishment
even though the US military was never
actually a substantial presence so those
are the general tenants of the Lost
Cause myth they emphasize the good of
slavery for slaves downplay or denies
slavery's role lionized southerners
loyalty say the Civil War was purely
northern aggression and portray
reconstruction as punitive by denying
civil rights legislation you can see how
the whole system kind of works together
and how it's built upon racism but as
with any mythology there is a grain of
truth to the lost cause and going point
by point when they're saying slavery was
good for slaves what they're often
complaining about is how slavery is
portrayed in the media we're all slave
owners
are portrayed as being the absolute
worst they possibly could be many
portrayals clearly violate the slave
codes that were the law at the time even
in 1852 when Harriet Beecher Stowe
published Uncle Tom's Cabin the South
went into an uproar about how the novel
was completely inaccurate to how slavery
worked in the south and in fact the
criticism was so strong that a year
after publication Stowe actually
published a response called a key to
Uncle Tom's Cabin the reaction to her
novel was so strong that when she met
with Abraham Lincoln in 1862 Lincoln
said so you are the little woman who
wrote the book that started this great
war so it is a delicate balancing act
when portraying slavery because
obviously you don't want to go around
saying that it was nice but it's also
easy to go too far in the other
direction and when they do that they
lend credence to the lost cause a more
recent example as the backlash against
the 1619 project this is a bunch of
journalists backed by the New York Times
who are creating a school syllabus
focused on the legacy of slavery as the
sole driver of American history many
historians have rightly denounced this
obvious sensationalism but that's just
what journalists do understandably such
sensationalism fuels lost cause or
retrenchment
since now they have proof of people
using inaccuracies for political
pandering engaging in the same
sensationalism as Stowe allows lost
causes to deny history which becomes
especially pronounced when they downplay
or denies slavery's role in the Civil
War the grain of truth there is that the
causes of the Civil War are super
complicated in fact all wars are
extremely complicated
that's why historians argue about what
the causes were even to this day but
ultimately slavery was at the root of
the major causes of secession in fact
the declarations of secession make that
pretty clear because they simply can't
stop talking about how slavery is their
way of life and that it's threatened by
Abraham Lincoln being elected
the vice president of the Confederacy
made it quite clear in what is called
the cornerstone speech what role slavery
took in southern secession he said the
Confederacy's foundations are laid its
cornerstone rests upon the great truth
that the Negro is not equal to the white
man that slavery subordination to the
superior race is his natural and normal
condition this our new government is the
first in the history of the world based
upon this great physical philosophical
and moral truth so while the causes are
complicated they almost always boil down
to slavery in one way or another in
return for this obvious problem with
their myth lost cause errs tend to
emphasize the loyalty of soldiers you
know they say that's not why most
Confederate soldiers were fighting they
fought out of loyalty to their state but
why a soldier fights doesn't change the
causes belly a causes belly as in the
cause of a war is always complicated and
what the soldiers believe on the ground
doesn't matter to that causes belly plus
you'll find that a lot of Confederate
soldiers actually did believe they were
fighting for slavery and emphasized that
in their journals as in something that
they were writing for themselves so we
can glean their motivations pretty well
from that and yeah many of them actually
were very much fighting for slavery they
saw that Lincoln's election might
threaten that peculiar institution as
they called it but in either case it
doesn't matter what the soldiers believe
here's a fellow youtuber who's actually
spent a lot of time talking about this
specific subject making a bit about
responding to comments saying exactly
this part of the myth checkmates Lincoln
Heights this perspective is so bias
yes slavery was in the mix but self
really complex and not ever southern red
fought for slavery hell even Confederate
generals were against the practice so do
a big homework sonic that's a lie
most Confederate Gen
absolutely approved of slavery and your
average Confederate soldier knowingly
fought to preserve it no they didn't yes
they did no they didn't yes they did I
don't give a rat's ass about them rich
southern politicians whose aims were to
preserve slavery they should have been
hanged but the common soldier didn't
give a [__] about slaves of slavery they
were too poor yeah here's the thing and
I know you're not gonna want to hear
this but they did give a [__] multiple
books have been written about this topic
yeah Confederate soldiers went to war
for a variety of reasons were they
defending their homes and families from
invasion yes but they also believed that
preserving slavery was in the
Confederacy's best interest his channel
is called a ton she films so be sure to
go over and check out his channel
there's a whole lot of stuff like that
and is pretty entertaining anyways in
terms of Northern Aggression the grain
of truth here is actually about
perspective so think about it this way a
rebellion is only a revolution when it's
successful we might call it the War of
the rebellion but to a southerner at the
time they'd argued that the Confederacy
was a completely sovereign entity even
though it was not recognized by the
Union and therefore any military action
whether peaceful or not can be
interpreted as aggression that means
maintaining forts supplying those forts
and pretty much everything that had in
that Sumpter they'd argue they were
defending their homeland that
maintaining it as a Union fort was an
act of aggression which is their
justification for shooting first
regardless of the fact that wouldn't be
considered a Just Cause even at the time
and then there's some further parts to
that in the way that the war itself was
conducted for instance there was the
Anaconda plan in which the u.s.
blockaded itself now according to
international law at that point in time
and even today a blockade can only be
erected on a sovereign entity at least
if other countries are supposed to abide
by that blockade so in effect the
Anaconda plan was a tacit admit
of southern sovereignty this really gets
reinforced when the Union started using
a total war strategy with things like
the destruction of Sherman's march it
becomes very easy to argue that the
north is the aggressor of course that
forgets that people like the beloved
Stonewall Jackson advocated total war
strategy from the beginning of the war
to attack the Union he wanted to destroy
his own hometown and of course all of
this stuff about sovereignty and
aggression completely misses the fact
that sovereignty must be earned
internationally anyone can claim to be a
sovereign entity but without the
recognition of one's peers that
sovereignty doesn't truly exist and the
South completely failed in that regard
no major power recognized them as a
sovereign entity they certainly tried
with Britain and France but those
negotiations went nowhere so ultimately
they can argue that there was Northern
Aggression
but the sovereignty of the Confederacy
was never recognized and finally we get
to reconstruction now they'll point out
immediately that some congressmen really
did want to punish the south but they
wanted to demote all southern states to
being territories and make it incredibly
difficult for them to be readmitted into
the Union of course looking at the
declared motives of individuals denies
the clear civil rights spirit of
reconstruction legislation the 13th 14th
and 15th amendments were all
Reconstruction Amendments the first
civil rights act in American history was
because of reconstruction the second was
because of reconstruction the
enforcement acts the military
reconstruction acts all were designed to
promote civil rights now they'll point
to states rights where this is an actual
argument that reconstruction was about
states rights as in the right to come
back into the Union and it had nothing
to do with civil rights and that that
was something that was being pushed by
Radical Republicans to cause some sort
of retribution they portray the violence
of reconstruction as retributive and
not that you've got Klansmen going
around and terrorizing black people but
the other way around somehow as in the
newly freed slaves we're going to turn
around and Massacre white people
similarly to what happened in Haiti
after their revolution but here's the
thing no servile insurrection ever
happened so the fear of retribution
simply is unfounded so while there is a
grain of truth as with all myths like
this that grain of truth is a pretty
small one but it only takes a pebble to
create a sand dune now interestingly
enough the lost cause didn't just
coalesce in a fully fledged ideology
like it is today as with any kind of
abstraction it has to be built over time
so right after the Civil War many
southerners felt the need to explain why
they seceded in fact one of these first
books was called the lost cause in 1866
by Edward a Pollard four years later
when robert e lee died one of the
eulogies written for him by Jubal Early
practically defined what the Lost Cause
would be but by 1870 it wasn't that
strong of an ideology it would take
another few decades for the lost cause
to be widely accepted but it became more
and more accepted as Confederates
started joining each other and reunions
and writing memoirs these guys
emphasized their service and patriotism
and incidentally reinforced the lost
cause as a consequence the ex-president
of the Confederacy Jefferson Davis
started doing speaking tours in the
1880s and completing his own history of
the Confederacy and all of this helped
the Lost Cause gained notoriety
eventually people started making
remembrances and political connections
so for instance you had Confederate
decoration day the origin of our
Memorial Day which interestingly enough
Confederate decoration day actually
began before Union decoration day and
the main idea is that everybody would go
out and stick little flags and
decorations on the graves of the fallen
by the way this is not actually the
Confederate flag
but a distortion of the Confederate Jack
the flag that you're used to seeing in
terms of the Confederate flag was never
actually the Confederate flag so they
can't even get that right then towards
the end of Reconstruction you had
Redeemer Democrats now these guys wanted
to redeem the south for white supremacy
because the civil rights legislation of
reconstruction and actually allowed a
great deal of freedom for X slaves and
of course when coming from a group that
emphasized white supremacy they'd want
to go back to that and so Redeemer
Democrats wanted to redeem the south by
making it white supremacists again but
in doing so they couldn't be as overt as
they were during the Confederate days so
they had to come up with new
disenfranchisement laws
you couldn't have guys riding around in
masks intimidating black people from
voting instead you had to do it in much
more subtle ways so you had groups like
the red shirts in the white League
committing terrorism as a component of
the Redeemers in effect the terrorists
drove the black vote away while the
Redeemers came up with legislation to
disenfranchise that black vote and in
doing so they could legitimize the lost
cause because black people were no
longer given a voice so this new South
could say all kinds of wacky stuff about
slavery being good for slaves and
whatnot because they had no
countervailing voices to contradict them
and finally in 1889 a group formed
called the United Confederate Veterans
this was much like the Grand Army of the
Republic but for Confederate soldiers
and as those soldiers started dying off
there were offshoots like the Sons of
Confederate Veterans
and the United Daughters in the
Confederacy and especially the UDC
played an integral role in pushing
remembrance and political connections so
these groups would sponsor statues and
picnics and various events all of which
pushed the Lost Cause forward but
simultaneously when these statues and
picnics started going up so too did Jim
Crow for the Redeemer Democrats had
finally redeemed the south by
segregating it but for the most part
this remained a southern
prior to the 20th century but at the
turn of the century
there was a real need to unify the
nation when the u.s. declared war on
Spain in 1898 President McKinley
purposely chose ex Confederate General
Joe wheeler as head of the cavalry
division thereby symbolically reunifying
the nation through an ex Confederate the
Civil War had defined what the United
States was as a nation and the Lost
Cause allowed historians to explain away
how a nation once divided could unify
again you see the Lost Cause was
ultimately nationalized by historians
the US history profession was a fairly
new thing for instance the first history
PhD in the United States was only earned
in 1882 the American Historical
Association was founded in 1884 and at
that point in time the history
profession generally followed Leopold
von rönn quz model so they wrote
histories of the nation and wrote it
backwards as if that nation always
existed history was founded as a
nation-building project and of course
the Lost Cause got muddled in with all
that cn folks like Theodore Roosevelt
and Fred rejection Turner down playing
the role of slavery in American history
they purposefully omitted that stuff or
said it wasn't as important as a way of
defining the character of the United
States for instance Frederick Jackson
Turner said when American history comes
to be rightly viewed it will be seen
that the slavery question is an incident
in the period from the end of the first
half of the present century as in the
19th century this is written in 1893 to
the close of the Civil War slavery rose
to primary but far from exclusive
importance
you see Turner is saying don't look at
slavery look at the West he begins that
paragraph by saying the legislation
which most developed the powers of the
national government and played the
largest part in its activity was
conditioned on the frontier now there's
an argument to be had over whether or
not this is true but you can see how
downplaying slavery will
into the lost cause then there was the
Dunning school on reconstruction it was
named after a Columbia professor named
William Archibald Dunning and he
especially wrote history that was from a
southern perspective being a redeemer
himself he lent legitimacy to
disenfranchisement that led to Jim Crow
in fact one could say the Dunning school
was an integral part of Jim Crow and
essentially they were the ones saying
that Radical Republicans were trying to
shove civil rights down southerners
throats as a means of punishment then
finally there was the ultimate
legitimize er Woodrow Wilson when
Woodrow Wilson gained prominence by
becoming the radical new President of
Princeton this lent a great deal of
legitimacy to his historical work after
all he was a historian now I've talked
quite a bit about him so I won't go too
in the depth about his historical
theories but he legitimately believed
that the Ku Klux Klan had saved the
south from servile insurrection he ended
up becoming president in 1913 and then a
friend of his named Thomas Dixon wrote a
book that was adapted into a movie by DW
Griffith called The Birth of a Nation
this - I have talked about what but it
basically solidified what the lost cause
was and even worse it was
extraordinarily popular in Woodrow
Wilson helped that along by screening it
in the White House this is basically
what you could call the first Hollywood
blockbuster and as a direct result of it
the Ku Klux Klan arose again the second
incarnation of the Klan was founded
later on that year at the same time
there was an explosion of Monument
Building picnics and all that kind of
stuff that the United Daughters of the
Confederacy had been promoting for the
better part of a decade
all of this coincided with an influx of
lynching and further disenfranchisement
laws in fact it was so terrible that one
historian called it the nadir of
American race relations so the lost
Khan's by virtue of all this became
infused with American culture
the second clan was not purely a
southern thing arranged as foreign as
wide as California to Maine in fact some
of its strongest membership was in
Indiana of all places but the
nationalist historians got what they
want there was general consensus about
what the American character was and it
followed that Frederick Jackson Turner
model that's part of why the western
genre was so prominent it was partly
built on the denial of the role of
slavery from 1915 onwards there were a
bunch of places where Confederate heroes
are portrayed as morally equivalent to
the unions and Stonewall Jackson was
trash himself him leave all the rest of
them Rebs
you tone and sometimes even greater with
things like Gone with the Wind
where reconstruction is portrayed as
ravaging the south and destroying the
quaint ways that used to be
then there was Disney's song of the
south that characterized a wonderful
relationship between master and slave
that teaches the Masters son some sort
of life lesson this cultural infusion
made its way into textbooks especially
with the sponsorship of the UDC
it's only recently that southern
textbooks are starting to get rid of
lost cause ideology and many people in
the comments might very well attest to
having been taught the lost cause as a
child and that's how all this works
it gets legitimized by historians and
then infused into the culture and spread
further and further and further
for instance probably the greatest
Western of all time The Searchers John
Wayne's character is a Confederate
veteran figure a man's only good for one
off at a time I took mine to the
Confederate States of America
and also what comes with cultural
infusion is the watering down of the
myth this is where people start saying
things like heritage not hate where the
Mississippi flag in 1894 started off as
a clear representation of Jim Crow but
with the dukes of hazzard the horn is
playing Dixie and the car is called
General Lee with a confederate flag
plainly posted on the roof
but you see that was just part of
southern identity at that point they
really did believe that it was just
heritage not hate and that's the power
of the lost cause or any myth for that
matter it provides identity but luckily
things started to change with the
success of the civil rights movement in
the mid 1960s participants could
remember people waving Confederate flags
specifically to continue Jim Crow and so
of course they began to fight against it
and right alongside all of this was the
rise of the new left this new left
sought to continue fighting for civil
rights into the latter half of the 20th
century
they brought their ideology along as
more and more of them became historians
who continued to revise history as the
profession does these revisionists D
mythologized the lost cause by the time
Eric Foner was writing his monumental
book on reconstruction revisionism was
in full swing and those historians like
Eric Foner himself clearly illustrated
the association between lost cause
mythology and racism of course there was
a severe conservative backlash as people
started seeing the myth challenged this
backlash by the way is called the
culture wars one of the key sticking
points for the culture wars was whether
or not you wanted to push the Lost Cause
myth in fact the person who gave the
name to this conflict over America's
very identity whose name is Pat Buchanan
later clarified his position on what the
culture wars meant by saying demands are
heard throughout the South that replicas
of the battle flag of the Confederacy be
removed from state flags in public
buildings the old iron Confederate
soldiers who stood for decades in the
town square must be removed after all he
fought in an ignoble cause slavery
versus freedom that's all it's about
they tell us but go up to Gettysburg and
park your car behind the Union Center
look across the mile-long field and
visualize 15,000 men and boys forming up
at the treeline
see them walking across into the fire of
Kenan & Gun knowing they would never get
back never see home again 9 of 10 never
even owned a slave they were fighting
for the things for which men have always
fought family faith friends and country
for the ashes of their fathers and the
temples of their gods even in 1992 and
on into the present you can hear lost
causes like Buchanan subtly trying to
dilute the truth with a lost cause all
for the sake of preserving some sort of
nationalist identity but eventually the
new left one out and a much better
version of events is typically taught in
school but southern identity is wrapped
up in this myth and it is often simply
to maintain a sense of self rather than
hating others just as American Western
identity is wrapped up in the frontier
myth and liking Wild West movies doesn't
mean you want to scalp some engines same
with southerners simply admiring their
rebellious past regardless of the
problems with that people can appreciate
something despite its flaws we don't
need to destroy these reminders of a
sordid past instead let that past
continually remind us that we're better
now the full version of the Lost Cause
is a conspiracy theory because you've
got to pretend that historians conspire
to lie about history so I won't abide by
lost cause errs on this channel but that
doesn't mean that people are aware of
the darker connotations when they wave a
confederate flag or something along
those lines they really believe it's
simply heritage not hate heck South
Carolina was the first to secede so
they've kind of got some special claim
to that symbol though I'd argue they
should use either their secession flag
or the Moultrie flag they used during
the Revolutionary War
after all if it's supposed to be about
states rights why not use the flag that
represents each state in either case
there was a high-profile usage of the
lost cause in that state that deafened
any non hateful form of the myth for
instance there was the Charleston Church
shooting in 2015 it was clearly a
targeted hate crime for the church has
mainly black parishioners
and of course the shooter prominently
featured himself with a photograph
holding the Confederate flag since it
was in South Carolina and the South
Carolina and Capitol was still flying a
confederate flag this prompted an entire
debate about whether the Confederate
flag was a symbol of hate and if it
should be taken down which eventually it
was and that's been the general dynamic
for the last decade or so that these
Lost Cause memorials and symbols are
steadily being taken down that was what
the main protest was in Charlottesville
so as you can see with all of this the
loss causes a pretty ambiguous thing it
actually doesn't necessarily show a
hateful disposition the entire myth is
founded in races but it's been submerged
in various ways over the years but I
don't even know if it's the most harmful
American myth the frontier myth might
very well have caused a great deal more
of human misery but that's the idea with
all of this mythology even when it's
harmful is still an integral part of
history and outright denying these
things can often end up spreading the
myth just as much as fighting it perhaps
that's not what Sun Tzu meant when he
said know thine enemy but in today's
world of bigotry on the Internet
knowing thine enemy means knowing their
myths
you
[Music]